Je viens juste de récupérer mon fils à l'école, j'ai été
témoin d'un épisode d'intimidation sonner le
directeur et je veux que les gens connaissent les
parents éducateurs enseignants c'est l'
effet que l'intimidation a c'est ce que fait l'
intimidation alors pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît éduquer
vos enfants vos familles vos amis
parce que  tout ce qu'il faut, c'est un
instant de plus et vous vous demandez pourquoi les enfants se
tuent et c'est l'
impact que l'intimidation a sur un
enfant de neuf ans qui veut juste aller à l'école recevoir
une éducation pour s'amuser mais
chaque jour flippant quelque chose  arrive
un autre épisode une autre intimidation un autre
déchiré un autre injure c'est ce
qu'il fait et je veux que les gens
sachent à quel point cela nous fait mal en tant que
famille de personnes d'éduquer leurs
enfants toute la merde anti-intimidation ne
fonctionne pas [ __ ]
et  J'ai un fils qui est suicidaire
presque tous les jours
et j'aimerais pouvoir enregistrer
tout ce qui se passe à chaque instant lorsque nous sommes
en public ou que nous avons une caméra cachée pour
que les gens puissent voir et  c'est le
côté que je ne choisis pas de partager je
choisis de garder cela privé mais nous ne pouvons plus le
faire
nous essayons d'être aussi forts et positifs que
possible
vous ne partageriez que les faits saillants mais
c'est ainsi que l'intimidation affecte
un  enfant de neuf ans, Dieu nous en préserve, nous perdons
un autre enfant par suicide à cause de l'
intimidation quotin tu es plus fort que
tu ne connais le mien et peu importe ce que tu as
un ami en moi alors tout le monde
s'il te plait, soyons pris l'un pour l'autre l'intimidation l'
intimidation est  pas d'
accord, la vie est déjà assez difficile, alors rappelons-nous
que chaque personne devant nous fait
face à une sorte de bataille, alors
soyons gentils, tout ce que vous voulez dire avant de
partir ferait appel,
donc la prochaine personne qui le fera